[MUSIC PLAYING]
MATTHEW GHARRITY:
Let's get started.
My name is Matthew.
I'm actually on the Android
Studio Platform team.
That means I work on things like
product stability, [INAUDIBLE]
integration.
And one of the most exciting
things I get to work on,
besides product stability, is
something called Android Lint.
So that's what I'm here to
talk about with you today.
So Android Lint is actually
a very powerful tool.
I think a lot of you
already know about it.
But you might not know all the
cool things that it can do.
So despite the name, it's
not just a linting tool.
It's actually like a full
fledged stack analysis
framework.
And it's really powerful.
You can write your own checks.
And I'm going to talk
about that today.
This talk is really
for anyone really
interested in programming
languages, compilers,
stack analysis.
It's also for anyone
who has had to deal
with bugs in the project.
So I think that covers
the rest of you.
Oh yeah, one last thing,
I only have 20 minutes.
But there's a lot of material.
So I'm going to go kind of fast
through some of these slides.
Try to keep up.
The good news is that at the
end of the day, you can go home,
you can watch on
half speed on YouTube
and you should be able to
understand some of it then.
All right.
Let's get started.
I'm going to go extra fast now.
So let's keep up.
[CHUCKLES]
All right.
So what is Android Lints?
Like I said, a lot of you
probably already know.
Even if you don't know
the name, you actually
do know what Android Lint is.
Because it's the
thing that shows up
warning messages
in your ID saying,
hey, you're doing
something wrong.
And so in some cases,
this is like telling you,
hey, Gradle might
be out of date.
Do you want to update it?
Or maybe you're not
calling a super method
in a method that
expects you to do so.
And right in Android Studio
in the ID it will say,
hey, there's some code
here that looks suspicious,
maybe you want to take a look.
And sometimes it's
warnings, sometimes
it's errors that will
actually fail the build.
So some of you might not
know but there's actually
a lot of different ways
to use Android Lint.
The first one is on the fly,
which is what I just mentioned,
where it's kind of in
the ID as you're typing.
It shows error
messages right away.
You also do something
called Inspect Code.
This is an action
in Android Studio
where you can run
a batch analysis
of your entire project.
It's a really great way to audit
your project for common errors.
And a related action called
Run Inspection by Name.
So if you have a
particular bug in mind,
say you want to find a lot of
thread annotation violations,
you can run that
Inspection by Name,
audit your entire projects
in one batch analysis
and look at those one-by-one.
Some of you might not
know actually though,
that you can also run Lint at
the command line with Gradle.
So you do something like
./gradlew lintDebug.
That's one of the
tasks that we have.
And it's kind of the same thing.
It will just do a batch analysis
for your entire project.
And the really great
thing about that is it
will make a HTML and XML report.
So you can parse the
XML report if you
want to do something
fancy with the results.
Or you can just take a
look at the HTML report
and go through your warnings.
So even if you know
what Android Lint is,
I really want to do a deep
dive into the advanced use
cases for Lint because
it's a very powerful tool.
So first I'm just going to
talk about configuration,
kind of sounds boring,
but it's actually
really important
for big projects
you want to make
sure Android Lint is
working for your project
and for your needs.
I'm also going to talk
about annotations.
It's a really powerful
way to mark up
your code to help Lint
help you even more.
So Lint automatically
does as much
as it can but sometimes
you need to tell it, hey--
you need to give it hints
to help you even more.
Also going to talk
about Lint internals.
I'm really excited
about this part
because I really want to give
you a good mental model for how
Lint works under the hood.
This will get you
set up for realizing
how powerful of a
tool it is and also
for writing your own
custom Lint checks,
which is actually the last step.
And that's the fun demo part.
All right.
So let's talk about
configuration.
The easiest way to see
what Lint is capable of
is to go in to Android
Studio, open up Preferences,
go to the Inspections window.
You'll find a heading
that says Lint.
And under there you can
see all of the inspections
that Lint has.
There's actually hundreds.
And most of them are
enabled by default.
But there's actually some that
are not checked by default.
And I encourage
you to just explore
these, take a look at them.
Because some of these might
actually apply to your project
even though we don't
enable them by default.
A really good example
of this is something
called Kotlin interoperability.
This is just a set
of checks that we
created so that you can call
Java code from Kotlin code
and vise versa.
And if you do things that makes
that difficult then Lint will
actually warn you right
in the ID, like hey,
you might want to rename this
function so that it's easier
to call from the other language.
There's actually
another way to configure
Lint, which is with Gradle.
So if you go into your
build.gradle file,
you have this Android
block, as you know.
But you can also add
a Lint options block.
And there's some really
powerful options here.
So this first option--
I'm just going to go
through a few examples--
this first option here is
a really powerful tool.
Anyone with a
really big project,
you really want to
pay attention to this.
So a Lint baseline
is just like--
when you add this
to your options,
Lint will take a snapshot of all
of the warnings and errors you
currently have in your project.
And what this will do is it
will give you a clean slate.
So you'll say like, hey,
I want to take a baseline
at this point of the project.
And forget about all of
the thousands of warnings
that I already have.
And then I only want to look at
new warnings and errors coming
in and new code that
my team checks in.
And this helps you get a handle
on the massive amount of code
that you have and
still be able to have
clean code going forward.
And then when you
have more time,
free time, you can go back and
look at all the baseline issues
that Lint has stashed away.
Once you do that-- so once
you have a clean slate--
either through Lint's baseline
or because you have a new
project and you just
want to say, hey,
I want to have clean code
forever starting now--
you can turn on
warnings as errors.
I really encourage
you to try this out.
It may not be for everyone.
But if you care
about clean code,
definitely try to get
this to work for you.
And then, like in
the last slide,
you can enable specific checks
that are not on by defaults,
like interoperability.
So some of you already have
this Lint options block set up.
And some more advanced
things I want to talk about
is performance issues.
So one of the reasons we
have this Lint options
block in Gradle is
because a lot of people
run Lint on their continuous
integration server.
And so they're
constantly checking
their entire application
for Lint warnings,
Lint errors, maybe they
even block pre-submit,
if you have a new warning
that someone just checked in.
But some people are
concerned about performance.
So just a few tips
here real quick.
Try to avoid the
checkAllWarnings option.
I know it's really tempting.
I just told you how
to enable more checks.
But actually some of the
checks are off by default
for performance
reasons, for example.
So if you check all
warnings-- like you
could say, oh man, my
time to check the project
has just doubled.
But be a little bit more
selective in the checks
that you turn on.
Also try to avoid the
./gradlew lint tasks.
There-- it's actually
a parent task
of multiple sub-tasks,
one of which
is lintDebug or lintRelease.
The parent Lint
task will actually
run Lint multiple
times on a project
for each build variance.
And so that's just a
really simple gotcha
that you should try to avoid.
Also if you can, use the
ignore test sources option.
So by default we already don't
look at your test sources
for warnings or errors.
The theory being that you don't
really care about how clean
your tests are.
But this option will actually
make it so we don't even
parse your test sources at all.
And so, presumably all of
you have really, really well
tested code, so this
option will help with that
and make things go faster.
All right.
Let's switch gears a bit.
I want to talk
about annotations.
Annotations are a
really powerful way
to just give Lint hints
for specific issues
that you want to look for.
So I'm just going to
go for a few examples.
A lot of you already know about
the nullability annotations.
Hopefully you've used
this a lot in Java.
In Kotlin you don't need
them because it's kind of
built into the language.
But we also have really
Android specific annotations,
which you should check out.
So there's one called
RequiresPermission.
You probably know
about this one too.
But it's just an
example where we
kind of annotate certain Android
APIs with RequiresPermission,
maybe like the
SET_WALLPAPER permission.
And then Lint will
actually do some analysis
on the code that calls
into this API and say, hey,
is the program actually checking
that they have this permission?
If they don't, then
we can warn you,
like hey, it looks like
you haven't checked
that you have this permission.
This might crash your runtime.
And this impacts
users quite a bit.
There is also one
of my favorite kind
of annotations, which is
UiThread and WorkerThread
annotations.
I think there just called
thread annotations in general.
These are really
important, actually.
So a big problem with
application development
is a lot of UI
frameworks require
that you only update the UI on
a single thread called the UI
thread.
And everything else has to be
done on the background threads.
If you do a network
request, you have
to do it on a background
thread because if you do it
on the UI thread, the
network request might block.
You'll freeze the UI.
User will be frustrated.
You might not even
see a crash report.
And it's really hard to
track down these issues.
So we have these
thread annotations
where you can say, hey,
this method should only
be called on the
UiThread or should only
be called on the WorkerThread.
And we have some analyses
to track that down.
So I'm actually going to do
a demo of these analyses.
Hopefully that's set up.
So let's switch over.
Could we switch
over to the demo?
Perfect.
Awesome.
So use your
imagination a bit here.
I'm going to go
through an example.
This is just Kotlin.
Let's say we have a function.
SPEAKER 1: [INAUDIBLE]
MATTHEW GHARRITY: Oh,
the screen is black.
You're right.
SPEAKER 1: [INAUDIBLE]
MATTHEW GHARRITY: Awesome.
Let's get started.
So let's say we have a
function called updateUI.
Obviously we expect this
to be run on the UiThread.
So maybe this is updating
the user interface,
whatever you want.
And then let's say we also a
function called networkRequest.
So just a really
contrived example.
And this does some stuff.
All right.
And unfortunately,
someone decided
to call a networkRequest
from the updateUi method.
So this is the problem, right?
As you can see, there's
no errors or warnings.
Threading issues like
this are actually
really hard to track
down in general.
But if you know about
these thread annotations
you can add the UiThread here.
You can add the WorkerThread
annotation here.
And instantly,
Lint will say, hey,
you're trying to make a
network request on a UiThread.
That can freeze the UI.
You don't want to do that.
So that's really,
really powerful.
I really encourage
you to use these.
Now you might be
thinking, hey, this
is really contrived example.
This is too simple.
Actually, what we have
in our application
is this Ui method that
calls a function foo maybe.
And then that function
calls something called bar.
And then that bar function
calls the networkRequest.
There's just multiple
layers of indirection here.
You're thinking, oh,
Lint can't help us here.
And as you can see,
it can't right by
default because for
performance reasons,
we don't try to do
these advanced analyses.
But actually, we do have
an analysis for this.
So I'm going to show
you an example of that.
You could do Run
Inspection by Name.
The name of the inspection is
called wrong Thread and then
interprocedural.
If you select that,
select the scope--
I'll just say module scope--
and bam.
It will find the call path from
foo to bar to networkRequest.
And I know you can't see
this error message on here.
So let me copy it for you.
And I'll remove the class names.
And so you can see the
error message shows you,
hey, you're starting
updateUI, you're going to foo,
you're going to bar, and then
you're going to networkRequest.
And that's annotating
with WorkerThread.
And that's an issue.
All right.
Let's go back to the slides.
So please check those out.
That analysis is off by
default for the main reason,
being performance.
It's trying to do a
whole program analysis.
It's pretty expensive.
So just use it when you can.
Just try it out
and see if it finds
any bugs in your application.
All right.
So next, I'm going to
talk about Lint internals.
This part's really cool.
So the way Lint works
is it starts out
by parsing your source files.
So maybe you have some
Java, Kotlin lying around.
It builds the
abstract [INAUDIBLE]..
And the first thing we do with
that is we actually wrap it
in something called UAST.
It just stands for universal
abstract syntax tree.
If you've dealt with these
kind of things before,
that might sound
pretty familiar.
But this step is
really important
because it means that
when you write a check,
you only have to
write it once and it
works on both Java and Kotlin.
That's really
convenient actually.
And then when you
write a Lint analysis,
you're actually just
operating directly on UAST.
So when you write a
Lint check, you're
just scanning the UAST
for your source code.
You're looking for method calls
that you're interested in.
You're looking in expressions
And that's how it works.
It's also important to point
out Lint actually works also
on all types of files.
So you can look at gradle files.
You can look at XML
files and resources.
This is actually really powerful
because it kind of gives us
a holistic view of your
entire application.
And we can provide
a lot more helpful
warning messages with that.
A couple more points here.
So type information
is available.
It's not just-- you're
not just looking at text.
You actually have the whole
AST with type information.
You can do things like
method resolution.
examining the class hierarchy
of the class you're looking at.
That's really important for
preventing false positives
and just having really
powerful Lint checks.
That's kind of what
makes Lint so useful.
We also have really tight
integration with the ID.
So one of my favorite
parts about Lint
is that it actually does
show you the warning messages
right in the ID.
I think that's critical
because if you don't have that,
then a lot of your
warning messages
will just be lost in
some buildup somewhere.
And it wouldn't be
useful to most people.
So with that, we're going to
move into writing custom Lint
checks.
And what this means is that--
Android Lint is
actually a framework--
you can write your
own Lint checks.
If you have something
that annoys you,
like either a common bug that
you run into on your team,
or just something that you want
your colleagues to watch out
for, you can write
your own Lint check.
You can upload it
to your code base.
And all your colleagues
will see it in the ID,
things highlighted.
Quick note here, Lint
actually has an unstable API.
All this means is
that we don't promise
that we keep it the same
from release to release.
The good news is that it's
not changing too often.
But no promises.
The other good news is that
unstable APIs are really
fun to play with.
So all right.
And with that we're going
to move into the demo.
So let's switch over.
Awesome, much faster this time.
All right.
So don't bother
reading code too much.
The example I want
to set up here
is that you see that your
colleagues are maybe calling
thread.yields pretty often.
And if you look at the
documentation for thread.yield,
there's actually not
a very useful method.
If you're writing very advanced
concurrent data structures,
maybe it's useful
but in other cases
you really want to avoid it.
It usually doesn't do
what you think it does.
So let's say we want to
write our own Lint check that
actually catches, calls the
thread.yields, and warns people
that they're doing that.
So right now it's
not highlighted.
There's no Lint checks yet.
I want to show you how
I have this set up.
So you already have some
kind of Android application
module here.
Here it's just called app.
The way you're going to write
your own Lint checks is all
you're going to
do is you're going
to make a Java module, maybe
called checks for example.
You're going to add a dependency
from your Android application
to the checks module.
And we have this nice
Lint checks block here,
which will make it
really easy to do that.
Once you have that set up--
and I know I'm skipping over
some of the details here.
But I'm going to have
some links at the end
that you can look
at sample projects--
so once you have that
set up, we can actually
go right to the
Lint check itself.
So here I have a class
called yield detector.
As you can imagine,
this is a detector
for calls to threat.yields.
It extends some classes
in the Lint framework.
And I already have typed up some
of the metadata for this check
that we want to have.
There's a name.
There's a brief description.
And there's an explanation
for how to fix the issue.
Maybe there's a
severity, whether it
breaks the build, et cetera.
So once you have
that metadata, I'm
actually going to start
typing some code here.
So one method to be
aware of is called
getApplicableMethodNames.
So the way Lint works is--
there's a couple options.
You can either make your own AST
scanner, which just gives you
total control.
You can scan the
entire source file,
look for whatever you want.
But for performance reasons,
we have these hooks where
you can register with
Lint for like, hey,
I'm only interested
in method calls
that have this particular name.
And so here, we're actually
only interested in method calls
with name yield.
And if I have any typos
it's not going to work.
So let me know.
[CHUCKLES]
Once you've have
that hook in place,
we have to write
the hook itself.
So here we can
say, visit method.
And I'm going to make sure
that's readable for all of you.
So this method
should really only
be called when we come
across a yield function
call in the source code.
So we can say, like,
OK, let's assert
that the method name we're
looking at is actually a yield.
So this should
always be the case.
And then because we
have type information,
we can do due
diligence and make sure
that we don't have a
false positive here.
Because maybe there
is another class
with the function called yield.
And we want to make
sure that it's actually
the Java.ling.thread.yield.
So here we're going to check--
we have some helper methods.
I'll type it out.
If you look at the evaluator
you can say, is member in class.
We're going to pass it
the ResolvesMethod node.
And then we're going to
give it the class name.
So Java.ling.thread.
This just means, if this
method that they're calling
is actually part of
this exact class,
then we can report the error.
And then I'll say,
contacts that report.
I'll give it the
issue that we hold
the metadata we have above.
I'll give it the node.
I'll give it the location.
So we're telling Lint like,
hey, here's where the error is.
This is what you
should highlight.
And I think I have
to give it a message.
So let's say, please
don't use this.
Oh, see, you should use a
more hopeful error message.
All right.
That's all it takes.
If I have no typos I'm
going to make the project.
Looks like it's done.
And if I go back
to our application,
bam, Lint has already
scanned your source code.
It's already picked
up your Lint check.
Right in the ID it says,
please don't use this.
And that's really powerful.
You can make this pop out for
your colleagues and everything.
So awesome.
Let's go back to the slides.
All right.
50 seconds left.
I'm pretty happy
with the timing here.
Here's some links.
I really want you
to check these out.
So if you've never read the Lint
overview on our developer page,
please go there.
It's got a lot of information,
both from this talk
and a little bit more.
Please check out the
annotations page.
I just touched on
three random examples.
But there are so many
useful annotations
that can really prevent a
lot of bugs ahead of time
before users ever see them.
If you are really excited
about this demo I just
gave at the end here, check
out the sample project
we have on GitHub where you can
actually write your own custom
Lint checks.
And it will kind of
get you up to speed.
And finally, if you
run into any issues,
we have a Lint mailing list
where you can go to for help.
Many of you might know Tor.
He's pretty active
on the mailing list.
I'm pretty active on
the mailing list too.
We answer all the questions
that get asked there.
All right.
And with that,
thank you so much.
If you have any questions,
don't ask them now.
But I'll be out in the
sandbox area afterward.
And I'll be happy to
answer any questions.
So please check out
custom Lint checks.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]